place à l'analyse maintenant avec vous
Christine dugouin Clément bonsoir à vous
vous êtes chercheuse pour la chair norme
et risque à Paris à Sorbonne Business
School pour le thinkin cap Europe vous
êtes une spécialiste de l'Ukraine merci
d'avoir accepté l'invitation de France
24 les victoires successives de Kiev
depuis le mois de juillet pour autant
est-ce que ça signifie pour autant que
la situation sur le terrain c'est
inversé au profit de l'Ukraine
alors ce que l'Ukraine a réussi à faire
en termes d'inversion c'est à reprendre
l'initiative et à impliquer et à imposer
son propre rythme alors que dans la
première partie du conflit si on reprend
évidemment enfin février mais mars et
avril et bien c'était la Russie qui
était à l'initiative et l'Ukraine
subissait et pendant l'été on a eu une
inversion de cette donne ce qui a permis
notamment à l'Ukraine et bien de
reprendre les territoires aussi bien
dans le Nord avec notamment l'iman que
dans le sud-est dans la région de Carson
où ils sont en train d'avancer même si
ça ne se fait pas sans mal sans peine
avec des besoins très importants en
termes de matériel militaire avec
probablement un impact humain et
beaucoup d'efforts et là on a aussi une
remarquable démonstration de stratégie
au niveau du commandement ukrainien et
optimisme du président zellinsky
lorsqu'il assure que son armée reprendra
d'autres villes du don-basse dans les
semaines à venir cette assurance elle
suppose qu'ils ont les moyens matériels
suffisants
là on a beaucoup de choses qui se jouent
c'est à dire que comme vous le faites
remarquer ils sont en train de gagner du
terrain et il faut qu'ils en gagnent le
maximum le plus rapidement possible pour
plusieurs raisons la première elle est
d'essayer d'avancer avant que l'hiver ne
vienne un petit peu figer tout ce qui se
passe la seconde c'est d'essayer d'être
de grignoter le maximum de terrain sur
les territoires qui ont été fait l'objet
d'une annexion par par la Russie et cela
avant que finalement et bien Moscou
puisse envoyer des hommes alors les
premiers qui vont arriver seront très
probablement peu voire pas du tout formé
mais au fur et à mesure des mois et bien
la Russie pourrait avoir le temps de
former les hommes qui vont être l'objet
de cette mobilisation et d'avoir des
unités qui seraient un peu plus efficace
donc il faut avancer au maximum et puis
il y a un dernier point en c'est que
montrait ses avancées et bien permet de
maintenir aussi le soutien des alliés et
des occidentaux dont l'Ukraine dépend
notamment en termes en terme d'armes et
ce n'est pas un hasard si le président
Zelinski a remercié chaleureusement Joe
pour son soutien notamment en armement
alors que et bien la Russie pousse ses
pions et pousse un petit peu cette
espèce de dissuasion en expliquant que
et bien puisqu'il y avait eu des
référendums que ces territoires étaient
indépendants et que probablement il
allait rejoindre la Russie et bien il
ferait part de la Russie remettant sur
le tapis le potentiel statut de
cobelligérant côté russe il y a ce recul
dans deux localités on les a nommé
raqués
et maintenant une mobilisation
supplémentaire quelques 200 000 soldats
plaît à l'heure au secousses c'est un
aveu d'échec un nouvel aveu d'échec même
pour Moscou ça
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
sur le terrain c'est effectivement une
déconvenue c'est un échec complet la rue
si a amené beaucoup d'hommes il perdent
du terrain sur ce qu'ils avaient réussi
à occuper et paradoxe allemand et bien
c'est présenté comme finalement étant
une relative succès si vous regardez le
récent discours du président et bien il
explique plus qu'à demi-modo d'ailleurs
de manière assez claire il a des mots
très dures pour l'Occident mais que au
final le choix de ces populations c'est
le choix du modèle de société russe par
rapport au modèle de société
ukrainien et des facto européens donc ça
serait une victoire en termes de modèles
de société
quand on voit la façon dont était menées
ces référendum on peut plus que
légitimement en douter et ce que l'on
voit c'est que ils sont obligés d'amener
énormément de masse et pour essayer de
camoufler un peu cet échec et bien dans
la rhétorique on va vous parler
finalement d'une guerre contre les
occidentaux que les Occidentaux sont en
guerre plus exactement contre la Russie
et au final et bien les forces russes
n'auraient pas my à à partir avec les
Ukrainiens mais bien plus avec les
Occidentaux qui les soutiendraient de
manière éentée et très rapidement une
toute dernière question Christine Ducoin
Clément si vous le voulez bien on avait
parlé au début de cette guerre d'une
guerre éclair puis d'une guerre qui
s'est installé dans le temps on
s'appuyant maintenant sur la situation
actuelle et cette progression assez
efficace des troupes ukrainiennes selon
vous est-ce que ce conflit va continuer
de s'installer dans le temps ou ça peut
être réglé dans les prochaines semaines
alors il faut toujours être prudent et
garder beaucoup d'humilité quand on est
sur des sur des conflits ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il y a un vrai facteur de temps
et que les territoires
occupés ont enfin sont nombreux et
certains ont été très fortement
solidifiés donc ça va être beaucoup plus
coûteux pour les ukrainiens et beaucoup
plus gourmand en teint en temps d'aller
récupérer des territoires comme par
exemple
Lougansk et donies qui sont qui font
l'objet d'une occupation qui ne date pas
de février mais qui date de 2014 donc là
on va commencer à rentrer dans dans des
combats qui seraient de plus en plus
compliqué vu qu'on va urbain qui est
toujours la hantise des combattants ou
qu'il se trouve et puis vous avez cette
double problématique qui est l'arrivée
de l'hiver qui est en règle générale
ralentit le rythme et la potentielle
arriver importante de d'hommes de force
fraîche alors qui seront plus ou moins
formés certes mais qui représenteront
néanmoins une masse sur le terrain ce
que l'on voit c'est en tout cas que la
Russie elle a pris le parti d'installer
ce conflit relativement dans le dans le
temps et qu'il faut il faut à mon avis
s'y attendre oui merci beaucoup
Christine dugouin Clément merci pour ces
éléments de compréhension